[Music]  President Obama unveiled a new campaign  slogan recently forward that's his new  campaign slogan and it's been getting  kind of a mixed reaction so now both  Democratic candidates President Obama  and Vice President Joe Biden are trying  out a new batch of slogans they're  really trying to come up with something  good we are not going back we are moving  this country forward change only comes  through challenge no you can't no you  shouldn't  don't even try no no no there's no jobs  for you then the economy's bad it's all  my fault  and I can't fix it I bet none China I'm  in over my head we have enough money  done to pay the bank honey and we have  to move you should vote for mr. Robin  it's hot in here and I apologize for  that a great mrs. Palin see America is  in decline  come on me no chariots  [Applause]  that's a winner make sure just run with  that come on man I'm serious